une affluence inédite le pavé du canal
ne s'attendait certainement pas à
recevoir autant de clients pour son
premier jour de réouverture la librairie
a doublé sa fréquentation par rapport à
un jour de mai 2019
la littérature est quand même important
dans la vie de tous les jours et encore
plus en ce moment j'ai envie de dire un
peu s'évader voir un peu autre chose que
toujours les nouvelles mauvaises en tout
cas à la télévision la réouverture de
toutes façons de librairie c'est
toujours un point positif parce que les
livres c'est une grande richesse
la commande que j'ai passé pendant les
vacances où s étaient pour pour aider sa
voix c'est un magasin que j'aime bien et
du coup j'avais envie qu'eux ils
tiennent le choc
mais ici aussi les gestes barrières sont
de rigueur employés équipe et sens de
circulation à respecter des consignes
qui ne masque pas la joie des libraires
de redémarrer leurs activités
les gens vont vraiment nous envoyer de
mai nous embarque alors vous ouvrez on
sera là présent des premiers jours on
viendra vous voir on vient d'en discuter
avec vous ça fait du bien cet échange
mais pour nous voilà de revivre une vie
à peu près normale de livres aird de
rediscuter de livres de littérature de
science humaine de jeunesse de plein de
choses de voir du monde
le confinement a laissé un impact
économique sur l'entreprise 10 salariés
ont repris sur les 15 employés par la
librairie les habitudes de lecture ont
aussi changé hier c'est la littérature
qui a pris son envol
plus de 150 ouvrages ont trouvé leurs
lecteurs un moment d'évasion en tournant
les pages d'un livre neuf